10h ce matin annabi rechal ministre
roumaine des affaires européennes
pénètre dans l'ancienne demeure de jean
monnet cet homme politique né en 1888
est l'auteur du texte fondateur de la
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier ancêtre de l'union européenne
japonaise well known in romania jean
monnet est très connue en roumanie
là-bas on le considère non seulement
comme un des pères fondateurs de
l'europe et mais aussi comme un
visionnaire formé oise
c'est donc pour moi un grand honneur que
de venir ici on ne peut que ressentir de
l'humilité dans ce lieu c'est une partie
de notre histoire
jean monnet a suivi un parcours atypique
il a démarré comme représentant dans le
négoce de cognac avant de s'engager en
politique il fut l'un des premiers
militants de la création européenne
la perspective
de jean monnet était justement une
perspective effectivement fédéral
on peut appeler ça états unis états unis
d'europe états unis d'amérique c'était
ce grand modèle qui était le sien la
visite de la ministre en ce lieu phare
de l'histoire européenne n'a rien
d'anodin la roumanie fête cette année
les dix ans de son entrée dans l'union
là oui oui c'est d'ailleurs une façon de
voir positivement l'europe aujourd'hui
consiste à se rappeler ses valeurs et
principes fondamentaux énoncés ici-même
il trace et continuer de croire en la
viabilité du projet européen
au final deux heures de visite et des
changes au cours desquelles des projets
de coopération ont été esquissées la
ministre a notamment proposé que soient
organisées des visites de la maison jean
monnet pour des classes de jeunes
roumains